voulez vous montrer pour une fois comme
on faisait des faits à pondre un qui m'a
vraiment ces bateaux il ya un camion et
une caméra quoi seriati et ya 14 elle
est exceptionnelle
les coulisses des frères vraiment ce qui
se passe comment est ce qu'on a à
construire cette séquence depuis toutes
ces années
regardez doit tout est révélée mais là
c'est là mon bébé de francs maçons de
merde voilà c'était le tout dernier
frère qui vient d'être tournée il ya
plein de gens qui disent mais comment ça
fonctionne comment est-ce que ça se
passe comment vous y prenez eh ben j'ai
décidé de vous montrer toutes les
coulisses voilà comment ça se passe les
frères on commence à 13 heures c'est
l'heure à laquelle on arrive avec le
camion rempli de costumes sur le lieu de
tournage bentalha deux robes blanches ça
fait trois ans qu'on se gare sur une
voie de bus donc on a pris pas mal de
[ __ ] faudra en parler à kaduna et c'est
ici qu'on a tourné chacun de nos frères
c'est la rue
la réparer c'est la rue montorgueil une
rue qu'on a choisi parce qu'à que des
looks de ouf
des looks comme ça comme ça comme ça
bref des logos mais pas dans mon équipe
arrête des gens pendant ce temps je suis
dans le camion en attente à l'affût du
moindre truc
[Musique]
d'autres questions piquantes enfin on a
quelqu'un cathy rentrer en scène c'est
la styliste qui m'habite toujours avec
un professionnalisme et un calme qu'on
ne trouve que chez ge n est pas ce nom
passe à la salle a peut-être besoin de
gens moi le temps antoine mon ami
d'enfance leur pose des questions aux
pères pertinente pour les faire
patienter exploser l'engin sans regarder
la télé vous mangez vos crocs de b mais
une fois qu'on a le bon look je me
dirige vers la personne tout doucement
sans être vu et votre elle en pense quoi
et ça c'est une équipe qu'on a terminé
direction la salle de montage
on a en salle de montage pour monter
avec monta rendrai moi ça va à fond le
montage toujours un moment de détente à
l'aimer c'est incroyable 200 ans pour
faire un truc mais pas comme ça tu mets
la blonde tempête mais c'est pas
possible mais un fake les rouges c'est
sonore ok donc augmenter avec les pieds
quoi montrent le clavier ou un peu des
pieds tellement tu montes avec tes pieds
tapis prend une douche quoi ça vaut
combien gel douche aujourd'hui à l'eau
assez pôle emploi apparemment n'a aucun
avenir
il ya une chance pour toi c'est avec ma
cystite sinon je suis en train de pisser
dessus à l'heure actuelle une fois
terminée on doit de la vidéo à la
technique qui donne la vidéo à la régie
qui balance tout en direct
voilà c'est comme ça que ça se passe les
frères depuis trois ans on espère qu'on
vous a bien fait marrer en tout cas
maintenant il faut que j'aille parce que
j'ai le câble à en double qu'il restait
morts chaque année